arlette laguiller bonsoir est ce que je
peux vous dire bonsoir camarades c'est
vous que vous allez comprendre est donc
normal ça ne me dérange pas
entre entre vous et vos camarades vous
appelez camarades
oui on s'appelle aussi par mon prénom
c'est des fois plus simple vous êtes les
derniers finalement vous appelez
camarades parce que ça se perd quand
même temps je trouve que si ça se perd
c'est dommage mais on est quand même
encore assez nombreux je croise a pris
comme ça justement en 74 vous avez vous
est présentée aux élections
présidentielles vous avez réuni 600
milles suffrages en 81 tout petit peu
plus les libérations en 74 avait fait un
papier sur les résultats étaient 5 5e
sur 12 ce qui était pas mal d'ailleurs
été pas mal hein j'étais la seule mère
des petits candidats voilà c'est bien
c'est pas mal et libé avait fait un
titre enfin passer par cissé dans un
chapeau il avait dit c'est un résultat
qui fait chaud au coeur
est ce que vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui
dira encore la même chose je sais pas ce
que libération dirais mais je crois que
si je fais autant de voix elle même plus
j'espère aux prochaines élections
présidentielles je crois que ça fera
chaud au coeur a des dizaines de
milliers de travailleurs qui aujourd'hui
dans les entreprises souffrent de la
crise économique qu'ils connaissent
l'insécurité pour leur emploi qui
connaissent la baisse de leur niveau de
vie face une bourgeoisie qui s'enrichit
actuellement même si elle a perdu
quelques milliards à la bourre en parler
de la bourse mais est-ce que vous
pourrez que ça fera chaud au coeur et
serge july 6 aujourd'hui
et
188 vous faites encore le même score est
ce que libération dira ça nous fait
chaud au coeur
écoutez serge july faudra lui demander
qu'on verra bien on verra mais ce qu'il
écrira je crois que vous savez moi je me
présente pas pour faire plaisir à
qualitel je me présente parce que je
crois qu'il faut qu'il y ait une voix
qui disent dans ces élections que la
classe ouvrière ne va pas pouvoir
accepter sans arrêt de sombrer de plus
en plus dans la pauvreté parce qu'on
s'attaque à son niveau de vie on
s'attaque à ses acquis sociaux
on s'attaque à son emploi et aujourd'hui
c'est ça qui est dramatique c'est d'un
coq et l'enrichissement et de l'autre
côté l'appauvrissement et je crois si
vous permettez je t'ai a lancé cette
idée et je crois qu'il faut que la
classe ouvrière se battent lumineux
comme ça justement sur les violations
pour changer quoi est-ce que
généralement les qu'est ce que vous avez
toujours trotsky absolument qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire faire la révolution il
faut prendre les armes
pourquoi pas d'ailleurs mais je dirai ce
que est ce qu'aujourd'hui en 87 88 alors
que les idéologies ont pris un méchant
coup quand même faut bien le dire est ce
que vous pensez toujours qu'il faut
prendre les arbres descendre dans la rue
et c est ce que prendre les armes ne
descendent dans la rue ça dépend pas des
révolutionnaires salah n'a pas dépendu
des révolutionnaires pendant la
révolution française
je crois oui qu'un jour il y aura une
révolution parce que je crois que ce
monde à l'échelle mondiale est trop
injuste des riches peuvent se payer
c'est sûr absolument
il a il les spéculant en bourse et
spéculent seaman ans maintenant ils
achètent de la banalisation d'accord
mais qu'elle est lequel elle pays
finalement qui à votre avis est le plus
proche de ce que vous souhaitez dans le
monde entier
quel est le pays où une révolution
trotskiste a eu lieu
et où finalement vous pouvez dire voilà
on pourrait faire comme eux il n'y en a
pas c'est inquiétant ça quand même
il ya eu la révolution russe à 1117 mais
depuis c'est vrai qu'elle a été détourné
par une jeune tracy nature avec la
classe ouvrière soviétique en rade faire
une nouvelle révolution sans russie la
nomenclature ils achètent des compacts
disques hitachi chemical est revenue une
nouvelle bourgeoisie vous êtes d'accord
c'est pas une nouvelle bourgeoisie c'est
un peu différent c'est une caste
bureaucratique mais pour la classe
ouvrière ça change pas grand chose
effectivement de ce point de vue là il
est nécessaire qu'une révolution à
l'échelle mondiale oui ça c'est certain
et je crois que aujourd'hui les
bourgeois peuvent être inquiets comme
les bureaucrates dans les pays de l'est
peuvent être inquiets parce que vous les
mettez vous les mettez dans le même sac
partout la classe ouvrière en lève la
tête et vous pouvez voir qu'il ya eu des
mouvements de grève en murs qu'il y en a
aux compagnies qui n'y en ait grand pôle
emploi qu'il y en a dans tous les pays
développés et que aussi dans le
tiers-monde la classe ouvrière bout j'y
pensais pas que les gens dont vous
parlez ce que vous appelez la classe
ouvrière
ils ont des traites à payer
ils sont ils ont ils sont un peu vous
voyez bien au crédit lyonnais quand même
les gens tous les noirs font leurs
emplettes posions pour payer la bagnole
le frigo ce téléviseur qui sont coincés
par ça vous savez ils sont peut-être
coincé mais la protée aucun de la
bourgeoisie et l les travailleurs ont
été tellement trail ou leur a tellement
menti que je crois qu'un jour où malgré
les traites malgré tout ça
de toute façon ils seront acculés à se
défendre s'il veulent pas sombrer des
squelettes mangue en effet pas puisque
je faisais ce que je n'ai pas le
sentiment qu'aujourd'hui les ouvriers
ils ont envie de faire partie de la
bourgeoisie ont certainement pas
certainement pensé que ça reste une
place avait pensé que ça reste une
classe en soi quelle image nous montre
la bourgeoisie une image d'un système
qu'elle est incapable de maîtriser on
l'a vu avec le krach boursier
vous comprenez on est dans une situation
complètement folle au niveau du monde
on voit en fait de l'argent avec leur
envoie des milliards oui que des places
d'une place boursière alors d'une banque
à l'autre travers le monde qui est de 50
fois supérieure à la circulation des
marchandises c'est à dire c'est des
bouts de papier qui représente rien
c'est une situation folle seulement cet
argent ses profits se sont bien fait sur
le dos de quelqu'un ils se sont faits
sur l'appauvrissement de la classe
ouvrière dans le monde des séries je
t'assure l'étendre aux surréalistes mais
alors maintenant on va quitter le plan
purement politique en 74 était le seul
candidat c'est le candidat la seule
candidate
on peut le dire et alors bigeard a eu un
mot un peu qui a fait florès à l'époque
il à dire de toute façon arrête
laguiller il faudrait la mariée qu'un
parent qu'est ce que vous en pensez
je ne suis pas marié nez avec un parent
ami agriculteur vous voyez je ne suis
pas calmé comme vous n'êtes pas qu'elle
n'avait pas l'air verra beaucoup visite
alors c'est toujours très basse énergie
vont des idées en tout cas je n'ai pas
changé
vous êtes toujours que jean faure et ben
c'est bien je vais bien c'est ce qu'il
faut non seulement le combat que je mène
il faut vous n'êtes pas mariée pourquoi
parce que vous êtes content assez du
champ du mariage parce que j'ai pas eu
envie de me marier je crois que je suis
pas tout seul mais est ce que c'est
parce que c'est extraordinaire
alors comme ça ma non est-ce que c'est
idéologique ou est ce que c'est votre
vécu comme ça vous dit non j'ai pas
envie demain et c'est mon vécu je crois
que si moche que personnel une question
qui me brûle les lèvres
c'est pourquoi vous auriez pu être bonne
soeur parce que finalement les bonnes
soeurs à défendre les pauvres aussi
passer ce que vous dites ça parce que je
crois que si vous aviez été un homme et
que j'avais faites de la politique vous
ne vous permets tu auriez pas de dire ça
oui tout ça parce que je suis une femme
non etc les femmes balauréa
mathématiquement on imagine qu'elle
sacrifie coeur vous accueillez c'est un
sacerdoce mais je les acteurs à tout ça
plein de vannes soit c'est ça il ya
plein de bonnes choses qui est sacrifié
pour les pauvres s'est joué je ne me
sacrifie pas je mène un combat qui me
plaît qui est le mien je lis aussi pour
moi parce que je fais partie de la
presse ouvrière ne lutte pas seulement
pour les autres j'ai envie que ça change
pour moi et pour les autres aussi des
tas d'hommes qui mène secondes à sa part
est jamais sortie nippone à 91 furet
dans ton monde a l'air d'un jeune
marginal
monnet curé quand on est une femme on
fait venir par là c'est finalement même
combat c'est défendre les pauvres
je défends les cours jeudi pour le monde
du travail mais surtout je les incite à
se défendre mais il ya plein de bonnes
soeurs qui se bat pour que l'époque des
pauvres vivent nus quand même si j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour les bonnes
soeurs qui s'occupe des pauvres mais je
ne suis je ne crois pas en dieu je suis
marxisme je suis matérialisent je crois
que les hommes peuvent changer et les
fans peuvent changer eux-mêmes la
société sans faire confiance en un bon
dieu de quelque nature qu'ils soient
alors de ce point de vue là non je me
suis vite mal gré mal gré la le marxisme
quand il analyse on peut être d'accord
avec lui enfin avec mars contre sur
toute la partie analyse mais sur la
tension est la crise économique actuelle
met en avant justement tout ce qu'il y
avait actuellement c'est qu'on sera là
pour en revenir au club ni pensée figée
quand elle vient de dire mais qu'est une
pensée justement parce qu'elle parle des
réalités qui est la seule qui puisse
expliquer ce qui se passe chez moi je
vais vous dire je vous aime beaucoup
parce que quelle que soit vos idées
politiques vous avez un coeur gros comme
ça arlette à j'ai eu un choeur puis j'ai
une tête de rat je crois et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de dinars d'études
abonnez vous je m'étais 1 pouces bleus